d'aller à leur rencontre pour
savoir ce qu'ils avaient en
tête, et leurs espoirs face à
cette campagne.
♪♪♪
- On est "gambler" un jour,
"gambler" tout le temps.
- Claude Desmarais
est un habitué du bingo.
- Ça désennuie, une sortie.
On rencontre beaucoup de gens
qu'on connaît.
- Mais ce qu'il souhaite
surtout, comme bien des aînés
ici, c'est de gagner le gros
lot. À 71 ans, il est veuf,
et la précarité financière des
personnes âgées le préoccupe.
CLAUDE DESMARAIS
- Si j'avais pas les sous
que mon épouse m'a laissés,
je ferais 18 000 $ par année.
Ça voudrait dire peut-être
plus d'auto. À 18 000 $ par
année maintenant, on va pas
loin. Le logement, c'est 1000 $
par mois minimum.
- 18 000 $ annuellement, c'est
le revenu des personnes âgées
qui dépendent uniquement
du Supplément de revenu garanti
et de la Pension de la sécurité
de la vieillesse :
des programmes fédéraux.
GISÈLE TASSÉ-GOODMAN,
présidente, Réseau FADOQ
- Ce revenu-là se situe
sous le seuil de la pauverté
au Canada. On sait qu'il y a
35 %des personnes de 65 ans et
plusqui vivent avec 20 000 $
ou moins par année.
- Pour la FADOQ,
c'est primordial d'augmenter
ces prestations, surtout
avec la pandémie.
- Il y a eu des besoins criants
partout dans les provinces
et territoires, donc le
rehaussement de ce financement-
là doit se faire, pas de façon
temporaire, mais doit être
de façon permanente.
- Les Libéraux prévoient
une hausse de 10 % de la Pension
de la sécurité de la vieillesse
à partir de 2022.
Entre-temps, les aînés ont reçu
cette semaine un paiement
unique de 500 $, deux mesures
qui visent seulement
les 75 ans et plus.
- Vous n'avez pas reçu
le chèque de 500 $?
- Non, non, lui il est barré
de sur ma liste. Il est barré.
- Expliquez-moi ça.
- Bien, 71 ans, on est
des petits vieux, là.
C'est sur que M. Trudeau,
il a perdu des points.
- De la discrimination, selon
le Bloc québécois, qui propose
une augmentation de la Pension
de vieillesse de 110 $ par mois
indexable pour les aînés
dès 65 ans.
- Si j'étais pris, si je restais
pas ici, j'aurais de la misère
à arriver.
- Ces résidentes de la Maison
des aînées d'Hochelaga-
Maissonneuve se comptent
chanceuses d'avoir accès
à un logement abordable,
alors que le coût de la vie
ne cesse d'augmenter.
MANON GOYER
- Disons que l'aide
gouvernementale, c'était pas
pire la première année, mais
avec le COVID, tout augmente
d'une affaire épouvantable,
la nourriture... Fait que,
ce qui nous coûtait peut-être
100 piastres avant comme
commande, ça coûte quoi?
130-140.
- Elles réussisent à se serrer
la ceinture, mais bénéficient
aussi d'une aide alimentaire.
- On distribue aussi
des repas congelés.
- À la banque alimentaire
MultiCaf dans Côte-des-Neiges,
l'achalandage des 60 ans et plus
à presque triplé depuis
la pandémie.
ANDRÉ CORBEIL, DG adjoint,
cafétéria communautaire MultiCaf
- On tourne autour
de 600 personnes, donc
de 400 personnes de plus qui
souffrent, pas qui souffrent,
mais qui sont au niveau de
la précarité... financière,
précarité alimentaire.
C'est énorme, c'est énorme.
D'où l'importance de l'enjeu
en pleine campagne électorale.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.